talk gender pronouns already dreading
this hi it's International
I'm a non-binary
Elementary School teacher
it's mix so kind of like cookie mix or
mixing bowl that sort of thing that's
how it's pronounced that is my name that
is the name that I'm comfortable with is
the name that makes me happy and I would
like it if you referred to me as such
see I'm not a mister or a miss so I go
by mix because that's what makes me
happy now you have a name that you like
to be called other than the name that's
on the paper right
for me I want to be called Batman Sonny
like how do you explain this to kids to
not confuse them I don't understand that
because then wouldn't they just want to
be called whatever they want the parents
or first of all let's start at the
beginning the international pronouns day
so now they they made up another holiday
because there's a thousand dumb holidays
Donut Day chocolate donut day this day
that day everything's got a day
mayonnaise day so now they they jumped
onto this stupid holiday train and now
International pronouns day which funny
enough is not International because most
Nations look at us and think we're a
bunch of idiots and we're allowing this
yeah so you could try to push it on them
all you want to pretend that the world
agrees with you but they don't because
you sound like an idiot
prefer to be called and that's the one
that you're going to use for me okay and
her her classroom now becomes about her
not about the children
not really comfortable with feminine
terms being used for me if you can find
some Alternatives that will be great my
pronouns are they them and she her thank
you so much for asking what are yours
they them and she her what does that
even I thought it was one or the other
that's a good point just not him her I
think that's out of the room for
children
[Music]
look
because they also believe in that Mickey
and Minnie are married and have a house
together
[Music]
okay
Haram you just got out of high school a
couple years ago no against the will of
God let me ask you get the Rocks do you
think that this person was truly crowned
homecoming queen because everyone
believed that he should be the queen or
do you believe that everyone's like dude
just this will be hilarious I mean I
would have voted if I was in high school
that would just be funny to have a dude
be the girl like if one of the football
players dressed up as a as a girl it was
like let's vote let's vote for [ __ ]
Eric because
you can do that like I I could go and be
the homecoming queen if I wanted to
that's what I'm saying knowing teenage
kids knowing what they're like they did
this as a joke there are not that many
that looks like a real thing no I'm
saying he's this this boy in the door
voted for him all the kids are like yeah
man we got to do this like it'll be home
and the girls the girls were serious
about it they're like that's so
Progressive so woke hi my name is Jasper
I used to stay at pronouns hi my name is
lyanna I use the demon pronouns this
video is demon what is that
so Leona uses they then pronouns in no
way that's real this would be lyanna is
my partner they are cute and I am theirs
I love them very much and I hope they
love
they love the demon okay it would be
lyanna is my partner do you miss cute
and I belong to Dean I love demon very
much and I hope Dean loves Demon's self
too
then interchanging the two would be
lyanna is my partner
they are cute and I am dudes this can't
be real I love demon very much and I
hope they love Demon's self too there is
a question that needs to be thrown in
the trash and set on fire and that is
when people ask me hey do you have kids
and I respond with yeah three the
question is always boys or girls and
that question needs to be removed from
every single language doesn't you need
to be able to say that and you need some
you need a lobotomy is what we need she
needs to you stop would you have a boy
you have sons or daughters you have boys
or girls like it's just a it's just a
conversation piece but it's insulting to
them that we assume their gender no
we're assuming their biology because you
can't be born neutral oh my God because
we're uncomfortable for the other person
when I respond with two girls in one
non-binary
and then they look at me like I have two
heads and they're like What's non-binary
again and you bother taking they didn't
identity she bothers to get insulted too
female it's actually genius they found a
loophole in the system and they get a
pave the way and be whoever they want to
be without stereotypes it's brilliant
so not she nope they them
yeah see I don't freaks I'll never
breeding freaks I don't understand it
either until my kid told me they were
non-binary college education to
understand it and I hope you would do
the same if and when your child you put
that in your kid's head same thing nuts
it's never awkward for me but for the
other person
you know it's going to be awkward her
child's entire life is now going to be
awkward everything for the rest of its
life from now until if it lives to be a
hundred shit's gonna be weird for that
kid for no reason other than she feels
like she's accomplishing something on
this Earth she couldn't think of
anything real to accomplish shame on her
shame on that mother oh God so my
teenagers are having a bunch of friends
over tonight and like typical moms I'm
really excited and I've got a bunch of
snacks and other stuff but here's what
I'm really excited about
so this is like our little Welcome to
our home
asking that everybody be respectful
um we have lots of pets
um but did you leave the dog in or out
then down here
letting all their friends know if they
ever need a safe place to stay that this
is one and then I've got name tags for
preferred names and pronouns and in
these little sheets for everybody to use
to let us know their preferred name of
pronouns and theme and pronouns I should
use of seeking to their parents in case
they're not out
and I'm so excited
yeah what do you think that means
imagine though like you can't just let
people just come to your house and just
enjoy themselves that you gotta meet
them at the door with a bunch of social
justice [ __ ] the second they walk in
and be so excited and proud of yourself
and the snacks that you prepared were a
bunch of poison chemical snacks why
don't you spend that time cooking
something nice for your guests instead
of putting out whatever the hell Flaming
Cheetos and writing up nonsense who's
this I'm saying that when you talk about
me you can say she so if you say Miss
Katie she's my teacher
I like her music
so it's just a way for me to show people
that those are the words you can use
when you talk about me
I just don't know why they have to talk
to this about kids so much I just find
it they make it seem like it's they make
it seem like it's like the biggest
problem the biggest problem on the earth
and it's not it's funny to me because
like the school system has already been
such a scam just breeds workers and now
it's like when your brain is that young
you can learn a language in weeks those
kids are legit Geniuses with picking up
new stuff like they're being Geniuses at
chess by playing at a young age
like if you give a kid like a good
curriculum you could turn them into G's
like Geniuses this is what I'm gonna do
with mine and be a nation of world
dominating but you teach them pronouns
from this young age it just doesn't make
any sense to me it's like I just don't
see the any of the reasoning behind it
it just doesn't make any sense to me
maybe I'm tripping just to keep us dumb
and distracted again dumb keep us dumb
and Powerless maybe I'm tripping maybe
we should just focus on pronouns what
are you gonna do putting this [ __ ] and
talking to children about confusing them
about things like their gender and
sexuality which are far beyond their
years is abuse it's emotional abuse and
it's putting heavy topics on onto little
children's Minds that they don't need oh
God thank you guys so much for watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfast yeah and me too
yeah you're always trying to leave me
out amen
[Music]
[Music]